finding yourself in a stampede of people
fleeing some unseen danger in the water
can send you into a panic or seeing a
group of people running on the streets
your first response is to run as well to
First avoid the apparent danger fear can
spread in an instant amongst all sorts
of animals so biologists have named this
phenomenon fear Contagion
so fear contagion is basically when an
individual observes fear in others it
also expresses fear and so you have a
contagion of an emotion basically it's
like an alarm system you can rely on
others to detect the threat in the
environment it's also considered to be
one of the first steps towards more
complex social behaviors it's regarded
as the basis for empathy
I feel what you feel and so exploring
the evolutionary origins and neural
mechanisms behind fear contagion
presented an exciting opportunity for a
group of researchers at The golbankian
Institute of Science in Portugal so far
this has been mainly studied in rodents
and in rodents we have quite good
understanding of the neural mechanisms
that in our life here Contagion
those studies had shown that oxytocin a
hormone commonly associated with love
and caring not distress was essential to
fear Contagion
but so far no one had tested oxytocin
and fish which represented a very
distant branch of the evolutionary tree
from mammals
would their form of fear contagion
follow the same behavioral and
neurochemical rules as mammals to answer
this question the research team
genetically modified zebrafish so that
they could not produce or regulate
oxytocin the team then ran experiments
comparing the behavior of these mutant
fish to the normal fish what we did was
to have two tanks where we had in one
tank the subject fish and then in the
other tank we had a Shoal of zebrafish
which served as the demonstrators the
researchers then injected a chemical
known to produce a fear response called
Shrek staff into the tank with a
demonstrator fish the first thing it
does is the zigzag trying basically to
escape and this behavior is Then
followed by freezing and the Observer
that watches this alarmed individuals
they adopt the freezing strategy
demonstrating that the fear contagion
will spread right through the glass of
their tanks however the mutant fish
lacking oxytocin Pathways in their
brains reacted very differently I
remember trying to see when they would
behave just like their Partners in the
tank but they behaved as Swift nothing
happened I mean this was like an Eureka
moment for me to confirm their results
the researchers then gave some of these
mutant fish a little booster shot of
oxytocin and ran the experiment again
this time the mutants seeing their alarm
neighbors Frozen in fear froze as well
and so what this shows is that oxytocin
is not only necessary but it is
sufficient for the expression of social
fear contagion a subset of these animals
were then used to look at the neural
regulation what we got was a snapshot of
the activity of a zebrafish brain when
zebrafish was engaged in Social fear
contagion interestingly I find it showed
that two regions that are similar to
this regions that have been implicated
in familiar species are involved in the
process of fear contagion although the
behavioral and neurochemical
similarities between zebrafish and
mammals fear contagion was clear a
lingering question remained did they
actually recognize that their neighbor
was in distress or was it just their
neighbor's movements that they were cued
in on
to find out the researchers set up an
aquatic movie theater on one side of the
tank a video screen shows a familiar
fish swimming in a relaxed State on the
other side the same fish is shown in
distress as you might expect normal
zebrafish stuck between the two screens
mimicked the distressed behaviors from
the second video
while the oxytocin-free mutant behaved
as though nothing alarming was happening
the researchers then replaced the video
of the distressed fish with footage of
the neutral swimming fish and allowed
The Observers to freely swim about their
tank mutants of oxytocin will just get
swinging meaning that they were unable
to perceive the differences in
this meanwhile the fish with normal
oxytocin Pathways seem to remember that
there was a distressed neighbor on one
side of the tank and gravitated towards
it in mammals approaching and
interacting with a previously distressed
individual despite the higher
possibility of nearby danger is known as
pro-social behavior and has been linked
directly to oxytocin and so I think
future Avenues of research are those
related to proto-empathy behaviors being
present in fish
as for the mystery of when and how fear
contagion developed in animals we cannot
conclusively say what we have seen is as
a result of having a common ancestor or
if the same selective pressure led to
the evolution independently of the same
behavior into distinct lines for that we
would need to do more experiments with
in the motionary branches that link fish
to mammals to try to disentangle that in
either scenario the discovery that fish
use similar mechanisms to enable Their
Fear contagion as us mammals presents a
tantalizing line of inquiry for both
evolutionary biologists and
neuroscientists to eventually reel in
foreign